Now I'd like to introduce today's speaker.
Today's featured speaker is Ada Poon.
Ada Poon is an associate professor
of electrical engineering and
a Terman Fellow at Stanford University.
Her research focuses on providing
theoretical foundations and engineering
platforms for realizing electronics
that seamlessly integrate with the body.
This is emphasized in a reasearch group,
by using a vertical integration of
diverse field ranging from physics,
while it is technologies and
low power integrated circuits.
She holds a PHD degree in
Electrical Engineering and
Computer Science's from the University
of California of Berkley.
And received her Bachelor's of Engineering
degree from the University of Hong Kong.
She has received the Okawa
Foundation Research Grant in 2010,
and the NSF Career Award in 2013.
So now I'd like to turn the floor over
to Ada for her presentation today.
>> Thanks to Stephanie and thanks for
everyone joining the webinar.
Before I start the presentation,
I would like to just give a very brief
introduction about my background.
I study at the Governor Mansion,
I study my PhD at Berkeley and
it is in the area of information theory.
For the application in
the wireless domain.
And after graduation, I spent some
time at Intel to design radios.
And also work in a startup to design
high data rate radio which is
the predecessor of what we
now know about 802 11 ac.
We tried to accomplish
gigabits of data rate.
After a while in the industry,
I decided to go back to academia and
totally changed my research area from
information theory to medical systems.
And especially,
what I would like to do is, I would like
to see if I can build electronics
in the scale of the medicine pill.
Such that we will use the electrical
method, electronic method,
to treat diseases.
One of them, a chemical.
For example, right now,
when we are sick, usually we will take
a drug, and eat a pill, and
hope that we will get better.
And particular pill here,
we're using a chemical way of
modifying the biological activities.
But biological activities can be
modified not only by a chemical way, but
also can be multiplied by electrical,
thermal, mechanical, and optical way.
The reason why the chemical way dominates.
If you're looking at the history of
the pharmaceutical, actually a hundred
years ago, all the different match ups,
not only the chemical ways.
The reason why chemical way dominate,
it is because it is a disposable.
That means that so
much of the bigger companies can earn
a lot of money by having patients to take
the drug and then to keep buying the drug.
But at the end of the day,
we can treat diseases,
not only through the chemical way.
And in my research and focus it is
because I'm in electrical engineering.
My research is focused on
using the electrical way, and
the optical way,
to modulate the biological activities to
achieve therapeutic treatment.
In particular, I'm very interested
to build devices that are very,
very small, like this one.
That I could put close to the nerves,
or to the organs,
where the therapeutic actions take place.
And I do believe that by putting
the devices close to where the action
point is, it would have less
side effects than taking drugs.
Because drugs go all throughout the body.
And that's the mission and
the vision that I had at the time
when I returned to the academic.
It is I really want to build electronics
or devices that are so small that
it could really put close to the nerves or
the organs so, for therapeutic action.
And in order to do that, one of the major
obstacles to make these devices very
small, such that it can put close
to the nerves or to the organs,
to tip the action, or
to the energy source.
When we are talking about energy source,
first of all we think
about using a battery.
And currently,
in most of the implantable devices,
the battery occupy more
than half of the space.
And it is in the scale of a centimeter.
And a newer method like piezoelectric,
glucose thermoelectric, and biopotential.
The problem with all these new methods is
that the power density is far below 0.1
microWatt per millimeter squared.
Let's imagine that we need to
consume about 10 microWatt of power
in order to do something useful.
Then the dimension of
all these new methods
are the source I mentioned will
be on the order of centimeter.
That is, we haven't solve the problem
on the bulkiness of the battery.
We just move the bulkiness of
the battery to the bulkiness of
the other energy devices.
As I mentioned before,
my background it has been wireless.
And the reason why we can transmit
data over the air is it's
because we're able to transmit
the RF energy over the air.
So how about we harvest
the energy wirelessly,
such that we can remove
the battery entirely?
And energy harvesting using the radio
frequency signals is not something new.
And actually we're using this long,
long time ago.
The devices that on your left,
it is a, you may wonder what it is.
It is a pacemaker, the first pacemaker.
And as you can see, that inside
the pacemaker it is like a metal thing.
That's a coil.
This coil, this is the coil, and
that it receive energy it is
also wirelessly from a device
that is put on the chest.
So the mechanism very similar
to our electric toothbrush.
You can assume the pacemaker is like the
toothbrush and then the device they put
on the chest, is it like the base station
for the toothbrush to get charging.
And the mechanism for both, I would
say that it is pretty much the same.
And the person who implanted
these devices, the first people
who implanted it was in 1958,
which is more than a half century ago.
He implanted at the age of 43.
After implanting these devices for a few
hours, he has to implant another one.
And at the end, he had 26 pacemakers
got implanted into his body.
And he died at the age of 86.
Not because of cardiovascular disease.
But it's because of skin cancer.
So 26 pacemaker.
And the earliest one is
the one shown here using
wireless powering to
power up the pacemaker.
And in the 1990s,
this is the cochlear implant which is
used in similar idea like the electric
toothbrush to charge up the devices.
So this is the internal device.
This is the internal device, and
as you can see that there's also
a large coil that is on the implant.
And because the coil is so
large it is just put under the skin, and
then there is a unique wire here
to connect to the electrode.
And the electrodes putting inside
the inner ear for the stimulation.
Now, what I want to do is I want to cut
all these devices and the wire and I just
want to have that part the electrode part
left, and this is my device such that
I could just implant it in the location
where I want to do the stimulation.
So in order to do that, the first
question that I have in my mind is,
why is everyone else using inductive
coupling as the mechanism to deliver
power wirelessly to
the implantable devices?
Which, as I mentioned, is the same
mechanism as the electric toothbrush.
So why this is the dominator mechanism?
What if I have the freedom to choose the
source that I could put outside the body?
Any shape, doesn't need to be a circle.
Look at the one that we used before.
What will be the optimum dimension,
optimum shape,
to deliver the maximum power to
a small implant inside the body?
So I start this program in
2008 as theoretical problem.
I said I don't mind and
I don't care how to implement it,
I just want to obtain the upper bound.
Once I obtain the upper bound,
then the way to get the upper bound
will give me intuition on how
to realize the optimal source.
And I have a way to justify whether
the source is already good enough.
WIthout the upper bound,
I don't know whether the source
that I'm discerning is good enough.
And the way I'm formulating the problem,
it is very similar to the way we
solve problems in information theory.
For example, in information theory,
we would try to find out what
is the channel capacity.
Without talking about how
to implement the coding and
the coding algorithm in order
to achieve the capacity.
I'm not going to go into the detail
of the mathematics in work but
instead I would like to
show you the results.
So luckily,
after solving the Maxwell equations,
we are able to obtain the solution for the
optimal source and the optimal efficiency.
As I mentioned,
I don't want to go into the.
In fact, I will show you a numerical
example where there is an optimal
source current density is trying to power
up at the wires that put on the heart
across the chest wall which composed
of 1 centimeter air gap and
four centimeters heterogeneous tissue.
For example, skin, fat, muscle,
bone, with bone, and then heart muscle.
The graph, it shows that efficiency
about the 2 gigahertz range,
the efficiency,
it is too old more than the 1 that we
currently use in this region,
in the inductive coupling region.
And the reason why we can accomplish such
a high efficiency in the optimal source is
because, let's look at the circular source
that we used to use in inductive coupling,
like the electric toothbrush or
the early pacemaker.
And also the optimal source structure
which is given in the figure here.
When we look at the the magnetic
field that [INAUDIBLE] is divergent.
As you could see from the the white blood,
it diverges.
But the magnetic field
from the optimal spot.
It converges, it tries to focus to
the location of the implant and
then after focusing to it it diverges.
And because of this focusing and
also the redistribution of the hot spot.
Which is the loss,
corresponding to the loss.
That's why we're able to get about
two orders of magnitude better
efficiency than the current solution,
which is based on the inductive coupling.
Let's take a closer look at what
happens on the optimal source.
The optimal source,
what happens is the electromagnetic field,
the magnetic field that is close to
the source and outside the tissue.
It is [INAUDIBLE] nature that
this is non-propagating.
But when it enters the tissue,
it becomes propagating.
As you can see, the majority of the wave
components are within the circle,
which is the weight number, but then it
means that it is propagating outside it.
It means that it is not propagating.
Now, this is very different
from inductive coupling where
the magnetic field outside
the source is non-propagating.
Within the tissue it is
also non-propagating.
And that's the reason why in
the inductive coupling method or
near-field method, the magnetic
field has limited penetration.
Because it's non-propagating outside and
it's also non-propagating inside.
While the optimal [INAUDIBLE] it
is not propagating outside but
it becomes propagating inside the tissue
when it interacts with the tissue.
And this is the fundamental difference
between the optimal solution versus
the one that we conventionally use.
And because of this property,
we are able to mix the devices,
and it predicted inside the body.
Now, so far we talked about
the mathematical solution, and
mathematical results to show that, what
is the optimal way to transmit energy?
Of course,
it has a set of heterogeneous tissue.
In order to implement this goals,
we final that the source when the tissues
removed it is not propagating.
When there's a piece of tissue
there the peel is fabricating and
this is not something common
with the antenna structure.
Initially, we talked to
some antenna people.
We tried to get help from them.
But they had a problem understanding
our requirements because it is hard for
them to decide on a source
that is non-propagating.
And so, what you see here, when there's
no tissue, it is not propagating,
then it is not internal anymore.
And they are true,
this is not an internal.
Because of this special property,
we have no choice but
bite the bullet ourselves and
I spent half a year trying to learn
the electromagnetic tools and
every day just looking at the optimal
current distribution that's shown
on your left for half a year,
and tried to find a source that will
limit this optimal current distribution.
And luckily, we're able to find source,
as seen on your right,
that is composed of some circular block
structure, and some circular loop.
And with this structure, We
could accomplish above 10% from
the optimal solution as you could see
from this curve on the receive power,
versus the [INAUDIBLE] the y separation.
In this experiment, we basically
the coil that is about 2 mm
in diameter and 3 mm long.
And in order to measure the receive power,
any wire that attach to this coil will
interfere with the radio-frequency,
that is the measurement that
we got would be inaccurate.
Most of the energy will be
picked up by your cable.
And in order to solve this problem,
we build a tiny circuit,
where it will help us the energy
from this tiny coil, 2 mm coil?
And then there's a circuit that will
convert this energy into pulses.
And the frequency of the pulses is
proportional to the received energy.
By adjusting the different
level of the input energy, and
attaching an optical fiber to an LED.
So optical fiber will not interfere
with the radio frequency transmission.
Therefore, it solved the problem
that the cable will pick up
the energy instead of the coil.
By measuring the frequency
of the light pulses,
we are able to infer that we
see power in this experiment,
as shown in the curve that on your right.
So also, we have this solved,
we put that [INAUDIBLE]
in the previous slide and
into a 119 pound pig and
put it in the brain and
also putting in the hearts and
also in the brain of
this porcine model and
with the transmitter which is
emitting about 500 mW of power.
So the reason why I say
500 mW of power is because
this is pretty much the average
of the power of a cellphone.
So if I use this number,
it should be safe.
It is able to deliver about 200
microwatt of power into the heart and
into the head, which is about 5 to 5.5
cm from the surface of the animal.
And the device that we're using
is only 2 mm in diameter.
And in order to put it into perspective,
what 200 microwatt a power can do?
A pacemaker consist about 10 microwatt and
different stimulation
consist about 100 microwatt.
So with a source that
outputs 500 mW of power,
which is pretty much the same
output power of the cell phone, and
the device that we are using is also
on the dimensions of the cell phone,
which is 6 cm, which is about
the size of the iPhone 5, not the 6S.
6S is too large.
As in able to deliver enough power for
both pacing and
different stimulation with this
device is that it is quite tiny.
Now at this point, we got a lot of
criticism from people saying that is
it safe even though I tried to make it.
The couple,
the [INAUDIBLE] part to the 500 mW,
which is the average emitted
power from the cell phone.
So if you can accept
cell phone these days,
then you should be able
to accept the state.
But this we got a lot of
criticism from people and
before I come back to academic,
I worked at early stage startup.
And the way we try to certify our
devices is to go to an independent lab
that certifies safety.
So I use the same approach.
I just want people to shut up.
And we sent our devices to a certification
lab to demonstrate that
the device is safe.
Okay, before we got the report back,
I just felt that this
is an academic project.
If it barely meets the safety threshold,
I'm pretty happy.
But to our surprise, it is ten
times below the safety threshold.
That is, it is really safe.
And this is the setup that the lab is
doing in order to measure the safety
of the devices.
Basically, the device is put
underneath a can of solution that
mimics the body and
that the robot that is measuring
the electric field in
the solution point by point.
And then finally, what's the perspective
absorption rate location and
do the processing and
give us the reports back.
When I got the report and
that final that it is quite safe,
I tried to understand why it is so safe.
So we go back to
the thoughts that we decide.
And as you can see that in our thoughts,
we fit the devices into 15 locations.
There's four parts, but
then we actually have
15 locations to fit the device,
to fit this thought.
The hot spot usually it is close to the
feed line, close to the feed region and
here we distribute the feed
region to 15 locations,
and that's the reason why we could.
Our thought, it is pretty low.
It is ten times below
the safety threshold.
It is by accident when we designed
a thought with just build the regions into
15 locations.
Now at that point,
we become more ambitious.
We say okay,
let's increase the transmit power such
that we barely meet the safety threshold.
In this case, we are able to deliver
above 2 mW of power at a distance
of about 5 cm to a device that's
just only 2 mm in diameter.
So 2 mW of power can do a lot of things.
Currently, we're trying to integrate
it together with the camera that is 1
mm cubed in dimension.
And imagine that it was 256 by 256 pixels,
14 frames per second.
We don't know what it's
going to be useful for,
but we feel that it's
pretty cool to do it.
Atiny camera that you can
look around inside your body,
to do something interesting.
So after we demonstrate the safety,
we also demonstrate
the real-time tracking.
Now I don't want the patient who holds
the transmitter have to keep moving it in
order to find the spot that would deliver
energy optimally to the implant inside.
This is not use of.
I would like to accomplish
this electronically.
And this is very similar to when we're
taking pictures using the camera,
we use the auto focusing.
And in these devices,
we are also able to do the auto focusing,
as you can see from the panel
of graph on your left.
That it shows it could focus
the energy to the different stuff and
different direction.
And in this example, we use a example
x to illustrate this properties.
When adaptation is on,
the entire sample x light up
when the device is moving,
within the thought region.
When the adaptation is off,
only those points that are near the focal
points of the thoughts light up.
And the coverage region,
when adaptation is on, it is above 6 cm.
That is, if the patient holding
the devices that it is offset by about
a few centimeter,
we are still able to correct it.
So now we demonstrate the theory
behind and then try to realize
the thoughts to accomplish the,
to approach the optimal solution and
then demonstrate the efficiency, safeness,
safety and also real time check in.
Not saying that we want to demonstrate
that, and to do something.
Now we move in the LED and
then we just put two electrodes in to
the same device and become the pace maker.
The pace maker is really easy to
build if you want to build one.
And here it shows the pacemaker
that is put on the finger.
We found a student that
with the biggest finger so
it could get a really good contrast.
We also put it close to a catheter to
illustrate that it could be delivered
through a catheter, using a minimally
invasive procedures into the body.
In this case we put the devices
using open chest operation
into a rabbit and it is the first
time I see a physical rabbit.
I didn't know that rabbit so
large it is more like a bunny to me.
And that is very cute bunny and
we had to open the chest and
stick it in the device into
applets of the bunny and
then close the chest and
internal are soft.
Here it shows that when the device is on,
and the source is on,
the pacing of the rabbit,
it is more regular and faster.
To illustrate the capability of
accomplished cardiac pacing.
So afterwards,
in theory by training as I mentioned and
my PhD in information theory.
The way we decide the source
actually is quite ad hoc.
I look at the source and
then I will try to find a structure
that will mimic the optimal source.
As I mentioned before,
the interesting thing about the source is
that when the way that it is,
outside the tissue non propagating.
But it interacts with the tissue,
it becomes propagating.
It might need to think
about the generalized law.
So I hope that a lot of you
are familiar are with law and If not,
then let's look at this photo.
This is the cloud window.
Which is the 180 degree of the world as
seen by a fish that is under the water.
It becomes about 100 degrees.
And outside this 100 degrees,
becomes stuck.
So what happened?
This is because of
the refraction that when there's
a ray that is incident from air
into material, the ray will bent.
But because it's different with the,
different pupity different index.
And there is a certain angle where it
cannot go beyond inside the material.
And this is called the critical angle.
Now, what we want to do in
our optimal thoughts in this.
We want to reach forbidden regions that we
want to reach beyond the critical angle.
Now this can be done currently
by using immersion lens.
But you don't want a patient to hold a 3D
structure outside the body in order to
bend the waist.
Now what we actually doing with our
optimal soft, it enters the incident view.
When it's interacting with it, it makes it
to be able to reach the forbidden regions.
That go beyond the critical angle.
Now you may ask why I
would like to do that,
why I would like to reach
beyond the critical angle.
Here, I would like to use time and
frequency to explain this phenomena.
In time and frequency, when we have
a signal that has hit the well wide band,
the signal in time domain will be
very narrow, a very narrow pulsive,
similarly in here.
If I can generate a signal that has
the really, wide angle spectrum,
that is,
it can reach the forbidden region,
forbidden angle, that it will have
a really, wide angle spectrum.
Equivalently, those with a wide, narrow
spacial signal, and that's the reason
why You see that, that the focusing
effect, in the optimal source, we're
basically doing some ways on focusing
to achieve a high pie chart efficiency.
And in order to accomplish that,
we are very lucky in order to,
actually it's quite simple,
it is made up of some metal strips but
each of them it is the wavelength spacing,
for
example in this case,
in this example we use the metal strips.
Within one wavelength,
we place 20 metal strips, and
each strip are noted by
different passive elements.
By adjusting the elements,
we are able to launch the ways that
it is the, with the reflective angle.
It is quicker than the incident angle.
It means that we already go
beyond the critical angle.
And we are able to reach the forbidden
region that is beyond the critical angle
consistently with the difference
in different angles.
It also confirmed that without
the material, without the tissue, no
propagation, which is very similar to the
optimal solution that we showed before.
And by superposition, we are able
to generate the angular spectrum.
The waveguide is able to
do sub-wavelength focusing.
As you see in this slide,
we're able to accomplish one-eighth
of the lambda in the focusing.
Into the material and the structure
that we're using is a ring structure.
Then loaded by difference
of passive elements.
Finally we use this devices,
this is the structure that we are using.
The dimension is about six centimeter.
Six centimeter in the width.
And this is our transmitter and
the battery.
Now, we are holding this devices,
which is quite small,
to do a half pacing for a pig.
But in this case we don't
do open chest anymore.
But instead we deliver the pacemaker
with a minimally evasive
procedure by drilling a hole
in the thigh of the pig or
in the leg of the pig and then deliver
the pacemaker using a catheter.
And we put it inside the right atrium,
right ventricle, and
also the left ventricle.
Here it shows the X-ray images of
the devices of the implantation and
also the location of our transmitter
that put outside the chest.
Put on the skin of the animal.
What we want to demonstrate is we want
to put the devices in the different
locations the heart and
to do a more synchronized pacing.
So here you see that when device is on,
it do the pacing in the different regions.
And off then the heart rate is slower And
when it's on the heart rate it is faster.
And there is a certain lagging delay,
certain delay.
When the device is on, there's a certain
delay before the heart rate increases.
The power for the left ventricle,
the required transmit power,
it is higher, about 200 milliwatt,
because it is The wall it
is much thicker than those in the right
ventricle and in the right atrium.
In the right atrium, the transmit power,
this is the transmit power from
the transmitter is about 34 mW.
So, here we demonstrate that with the
pacemaker with minimal invasive procedures
we are able to use our which
is very handy, hand-held.
We can even make it flexible,
very easy to use source to do the pacing.
And this is the pacemaker that we put in
the [INAUDIBLE] that compare with a penny.
A lot of times, people thought that
the silver coil is the antenna.
It is not the antenna, silver coil
is just for fixation, for anchoring.
The antenna, it is direct coil here.
The two [INAUDIBLE] coil and then
the electron that is putting inside and
one more electrode is
inside the silver coil.
This is the return electrode and
then at the tip of this silver
coil is another electrode.
And then all the other parts for
the pressure of the three electrodes and
electron is put with the epoxy to coat it.
So here so
far we just talk about pacemaker.
But as I mentioned at the very beginning,
I want to make electronics that are small
enough for
us that if you put close to the nerves or
the organs to do some
therapeutic treatment.
Pacemaker it is not what I want to do but
it's a very good way to
demonstrate the visibility.
In order to move on to our original
ideas of the bioelectronic medicine,
we want to do something to show this idea.
In order to do that,
I look at the neural pathways.
The nurse that it is
from the brain stem and
eventually I picked number
ten which is the vagus nerve.
At the time when I returned
to academics I always
heard people talk about vagus nerve.
So I think this is the magic nerve, it
can be useful in anything it seems to me.
So if I pick this nerve, there may
be something that will happen and
in particularly,
I am focused on heart failure.
So basically I do vagus nerve
stimulation in the pig model for
heart failure treatment.
In here this is our transmitter.
Now it becomes band it with
the adhesive such that it
could be adjusted and
stick it into the neck of the patient.
And then this is the receiver
that is put on the vagus nerve
and the transmitter and everything
are integrated in this cuff electrode.
And here it shows the X-ray
images where we impounded and
it shows the effects of the input
power versus the heart rate and
also the blood pressure.
Okay, and here we save about 20 mW
of input power from the source.
From the source that is under adhesive,
we are able to train the heartrate by 20%.
Similarly, with the input power
of about 20 to 30 mW we're
able to change the blood
pressure by about 20% to 30%.
And here this graph shows that
we can consistently getting it
from this process is reversible.
That is, when we turn on the devices,
the heart rates jump.
When we turn it off,
heart rate rises again and turn it off,
heart rates jump, similar for
the blood pressure.
And then, here it shows the dynamic
of it when we have the pulses,
that it is ten minutes on,
ten minutes off.
You see that the heart rate pretty much
follows the pattern of the on and off.
For the blood pressure It takes longer
time to get to the initial stage.
Therefore, the blood
pressure is keep decreasing.
So if we increase the interval to be,
for example, a half a minute,
it may be able to show what we see for
the heart rate.
But anyway,
this damages the visibility that one
application could be in hypertension.
Instead of taking the drug to
reduce the blood pressure,
now you put a patch on the neck and
then by delivering the electrical
pulses it could reduce the pressure.
So it cannot demonstrate the visibility
of using electronics to replace drops.
In this case, we are targeting, it is
the physiological state is the pressure.
Going even further so far,
we used the electronics to
stimulate the nerve bundles.
But it would be nice if we can
stimulate the individual axon
and here it goes to
the technology of cytogenetics.
So using light, so far, what we're
talking about is electrical stimulation.
Electrical stimulation
lacks cell specificity,
while optical stimulation using light,
we are able to target a particular
neuron type, so that's the difference.
And the current light delivery systems,
this is the one that is used in our
collaborative lab, Deisseroth Lab,
that is the optical fiber, and then it
delivers the lights into the animal.
And these two are wireless version.
One is from Japan and
the other is from MIT, it's a very
large headband that is put on the animal.
So imagine that have the same volume and
weight of your head that
was put on top your head.
I don't think you would feel
that this is truly behaving, but
this is what happened to
the animal experiments while
they're trying to use the wireless
light delivery system.
Another, with this it's for
the MIT one, it is also wireless powered,
you can see see that the coil are raised.
Here the rat wants many, many turns.
Now, in order to increase the area
where the animal can walk around,
researchers, in my opinion
it's a little bit crazy.
They put a magnetic sensor
into the animal's feet and
then they try to track
the location of the animal.
After tracking where they are, they turn
the coil that is underneath the animal.
So basically, you could see that
this is the smallest cellular
cell in the cellular network and
the customer, it is a single month.
And then there will be
long overlapping cells or
overlapping cells whenever emerging,
that whenever you go anywhere they
will locate where you are and
then turn on that cell.
And this is what happened to this case but
instead the human being, it is the animal.
There's another system
that developed by EPFL.
Instead of having multiple cells and turn
on the one that's closest to the animal,
they have the cells moving
with the animal and
then track where the animal it is and
keep powering it.
Now I think this is too much work and
I, when I encountered
this problem that we need to increase
the publication range of the system,
such that the animal can be
freely moving in a larger area,
I feel this is crazy and
I want to be lazy.
And in order to be lazy we need
to be a little bit more creative.
So get inspired by quantum tunneling.
We develop a self-tracking system
that doesn't require any electronics.
So we can be lazy.
Okay, let me play the video
to illustrate how it works.
>> A microwave cavity is
a hollow metal structure.
When it is excited by an RF source, it
confines electromagnetic fields inside it.
If we remove part of the metal structure,
for
example the top plate,
energy from the source will radiate.
But, if we cover it with a metal plate
patterned with sub wavelength apertures,
the honeycomb, energy from the source
will confine within the hollow structure.
There is no radiation.
However, when a mouse is
placed on the honeycomb,
energy will be transferred to the mouse
through the fringing evanescent field.
This energy transfer follows the mouse
over any path of motion on the honeycomb,
achieving self-tracking without
any tracking mechanisms.
>> The main use of the property is that
animal, the teacher of the animal.
Basically we are made of 70% of water,
right?
The dielectric properties
of water is about 80 times
larger than the dielectric
properties of air permutivity.
We make use of differences
in the permutivity to
do the self-tracking as
explained in the video.
And in order to do that,
then we need to study the resonant
modes of a small animal.
I think this is the most ridiculous
thing that I've ever done in my
academic career is to study
how a mouse resonates.
And this in war the drawing of a very cute
mouse in the electromagnetic simulator.
And then scale it more, enlarge,
and then we give it different
orientation to figure are where,
what the resonant modes are and
such that we can decide our cavity
around that resonant sequences.
And after we decide the cavity
which is where it can do
self-tracking the animal can
run freely onto a larger area.
Next we need to build the implant so
here it's the devices that were
built to put in the right
motor cortex of the animal.
We followed the same
implantation procedures as
the one that they did in my
collaborated for the optical fiber one,
therefore we have to attach
an optical fiber for holding.
Afterwards we would break
the optical fiber and then do the.
So at the end you would see that
the whole implantable device,
it is fully inside the body.
There is nothing that is like a.
Here you see the light coming out.
It's because when we write paper we
cannot say that the animal already has
an implant inside.
No one would believe you.
So therefore we have to increase the power
enough such that the light is leaked
out from the scalp such that
you will see the light.
But in reality,
it will be something like in this video
that I want to show what happened.
So we put the implant into
the right motor cortex.
We will expect that when
the stimulation is on
the animal will move in counter-clockwise.
In the left through,
it has a tendency to move left.
So it will move counter-clockwise
in little circles.
You could see that the animal
looks normal, right.
You don't see see any implants, but
already that the implant inside
the [INAUDIBLE] is [INAUDIBLE].
[NOISE] So you see that the circular
behavior, the animal doesn't
want to move in the counter-clockwise
direction but it is forced to move.
We're basically, controlling the mouse.
So here you see that the cell when
the stimulation is off, it's random.
When the stimulation is on,
it do the circling effect.
Okay so let me conclude this talk.
We talk about electrical stimulation,
we also talk about optical stimulation.
And at the end, we really hope that we
can build a device as small as they pill.
And you will get this [INAUDIBLE] in the
[INAUDIBLE] in the [INAUDIBLE] instead of
the chemical one and
that concludes my talk.
>> Great thanks so much Ada.
So if you haven't submitted your
questions please do so as well but
Ada's going to choose some questions
to go ahead and tackle now.
>> So first question is how special lives
will manufacture be or [INAUDIBLE].
Like this.
I would like to say that the technology
that I just described would have been nice
to also fit medical device companies.
They are translating them into
something that it is useful, so that's
why I would say that assisted medical
device manufacturers could make it.
And, to my best knowledge that
the focus of those are what
I heard from the technology office,
it is for pain relief.
Another it is for urinal incontinence.
So if this up there approve security, so
I will let the two status and
medical device companies to show it.
Because they pay money to get it, right?
The doctor showed that it could be acted
a put and past the airport security.
What kind of health problem is
this application focusing on?
As I mentioned right the two companies
that licensing our technology,
one's focused on pain relief and
another is urinal incontinence but
they may also work on other applications.
Those are the applications that I
heard from the technology office.
The longest that, so the question is will
the device have any immune response or
is there any inflammation when
the device is inserted in the host?
No, so far we only do animal testing.
The longest one that we
did takes about one month.
And it seemed fine when
we write the devices and
then and do the and
it's in the surrounding tissue,
it looks fine.
So, if these biodegradable
devices in the body,
as I just mentioned, the longest
we did it in animals is one month.
And I would also like to ask
of the other companies they
work on the bio-compatible problem.
This device has pulse.
And it require a pulse [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah of course,
it does not have pulse when it is
just the [INAUDIBLE] that
was wireless controlled.
It needs to have more functionalities
like a processor in order
to do the encryption and
decryption to make it to be hacker free.
Okay based on the energy
transfer in pass through models
are changes to the process of device
required for different body mark.
This is a very good question, now before
we do the animal testing we kind of
worried that the structure will affect how
the device performs, so
we have a lot of backup solutions.
But, at the end,
where we do the animal testing,
we realized that they're
pretty much the same.
We don't need to adjust the device for
the different animal.
So, I will say that it
doesn't need to change.
Because, the variation,
it is not too much.
Are you sure disappear able to
get continuous feedback
from neurological systems.
So the question is do you see this as
being able to get continuous feedback
on neurological systems.
This is the current
problems we are solving,
we're trying to incorporate
both our new recorder and
stimulate it because we have a wire
transceiver already built in silicon.
We also collaborating with
others to build the electrical
recorders with a few hundred channels and
stimulators.
To do the neurological application,
how do you remove the device when
the delivery or use is completed?
This is a very good question.
You should after we finish the experiment
to the animal we remove it But,
of course, in order to do that,
we need to really decipher special
capital, that is able to deliver it,
and at the same time is able
to unscrew it, and remove it.
What is the lifespan of this device sir?
It is, what is the lifespan of this
device, It depends on the coding.
For the one that we do actual study,
we just use regular apothis, so
it doesn't last for
long time, maybe a few days.
But for the one that we try to do the more
clinic studies, we need to send it out.
To outside companies to do special
code and said that it could last for
much longer.
If taken in two form,
how will the device go to the location
the body where it is needed?
So for the, if you look at the devices
even though we create in the pure form
there's some anchor, some anchors several
that they tried to anchor them into
the tissue or into the nerves.
Implantation is always a challenge for
medical devices and
therefore it require a lot of,
it will be applications that defects.
The way to implant the device,
it would be really specialized to
the type of applications
that we're targeting.
So I cannot answer this question.
>> So it's 11 and we want to be thoughtful
of people's time, so maybe Ada you can
pick two more questions to answer and
then we'll wrap it up for the day.
>> Okay can you explain
the critical angle more?
So critical angle basically when we
have a radar that is emitting from
air into water for example you will see
the ray for example you shine a light
from outside the water to the water inside
the water you will see the light bends.
And then it is bent towards the center.
And that certain critical angles,
where the light will not pass it,
when it is inside the water,
and this is the critical angle.
And that's called the large window,
as I show in the photo.
That's the reason why
the 180 degrees of the world,
It becomes only about 100 degree from
the fish that is inside the water,
it is because of this
critical angle effect.
Do you have any plans to establish
research into starting these
applications through
a wireless body area network?
Actually I don't really buy the idea
of a wireless body area network so, no.
[LAUGH]
>> Great.
Okay, so we are going to wrap it up.
I want to say a big, big thank you
to Ada for a wonderful presentation.
Your research and what you do is so
exciting, and for
taking time to answer
attendee questions as well.
And we want to thank you for
taking the time to attend today, and
we'll see you at our next seminar.
Thanks so much, and have a great day.
>> Thank you.